good afternoon everyone we're gonna
get cracking so uh
if you haven't already please make the
heading which is acceleration and we'll
get to that
in a brief moment um we've been looking
at simple harmonic motion
right and i don't know how many of you
have seen this video before but it's one
of my favorites
i've watched it well i'm gonna say
more times than i'd like to admit but
hopefully you can see why it's the kind
of theme that's just like
over and over again i can just sort of
watch this endlessly
and for me what it illustrates is the
beauty of simple harmonic motion
let me say that one more time this is
about the beauty
of simple harmonic motion we can
understand it we can manipulate it
but i hope we don't lose track of the
site that it's really quite
amazing to behold now i want to remind
you what we know about simple harmonic
motion
right we started with this idea of
acceleration or force acting upon
something
that sends it back in the direction that
it came from so you can see
that negative is really the key there so
wherever your displacement is whatever x
value you have
you take the negative of that so if
you're in the positive direction your
acceleration your force is acting in the
negative direction and vice versa if
you're in the negative direction
force or acceleration acting in the
positive direction and that's what sends
everything
back in its opposite direction and one
of the things we noticed was that
our old trigonometric function friends
were perfect for illustrating this
because as you differentiate
you can see you get this uh minus n
squared and you can recognize
that x there down the bottom in the a
and the sine nt
plus alpha and this is where we went
right and the important thing that i
want to get across to you
is that these equations down the bottom
here they're all time equations do you
see that
they're all in terms of t and that's
kind of handy like if you know what time
you know you set this experiment going
and then you can fast forward to some
certain amount of time you can know
exactly where something is question
it is supposed to be next double dot in
fact i even looked at that and i thought
oh i need to fix that and then i forgot
uh so it hits that's the acceleration
equation down the bottom of course thank
you trin for pointing that out
now the thing that i want to get across
to us today is that we had to
go away from the definition of simple
harmonic motion which is this
uh special equation at the top here
what's it called again by the way when
you have an equation that relates
a function with one of its derivatives
what's that called
a differential equation right we had to
basically abandon
the differential equation and work with
the time equations to start doing stuff
if we wanted to know amplitude if we
wanted to know center of motion
etc etc but what i want to do is take us
back to this idea
of acceleration or force in terms of
displacement because often
where you are is much more important
than when
you are when it comes to understanding
the forces acting upon you does that
make sense
if you have a look at a situation like
this do i care about the time like it's
just a
fixed image that shows you that
visualizes all the magnetic forces going
on here
and really to know what kind of forces
are acting upon you all you need to know
is where you are in relation to the
magnet make sense
so this is acceleration that we want to
all force
that we want to understand in terms of
displacement right not in terms of time
and in addition to knowing in terms of
displacement we might also be interested
in force or acceleration in terms of say
velocity right you might remember this
from the first example that i gave when
we were introducing
mechanics when you're playing at speeds
like an f-35 jet can fly
your shape matters a whole lot like the
fact that your wings are swept back at a
particular angle
and your fins are you know this exact
size and magnitude
they matter because when you're
traveling at these speeds
aerodynamic drag is kind of enormous
right so this would be a force acting
upon your
plane your jet that's in direct relation
to your
velocity right faster you go the more
drag you experience make sense
so this is acceleration not in terms of
displacement but acceleration in terms
of
velocity so what we want to do is
explore this
let me put this to bed for a second i
asked you to make the heading of
acceleration
and what we're going to do is think
about acceleration as
a function of velocity first
so a function of velocity or
as a function of displacement right
as opposed to a function of time
so i want us to think about what is
acceleration there are many different
ways
to define what acceleration is and
therefore what defines the force acting
upon
an object velocity is kind of the first
step right velocity is how
acceleration sorry velocity is how
displacement is changing with respect to
time do you agree with that
velocity i need another color
velocity is the change in displacement
compared to the change in time
right how do we define acceleration in
similar terms
acceleration equals
changes fantastic it's not how
displacement is changing it's how
velocity is changing so it's the next
step down
after velocity that's why we
differentiate again so what i can do is
i can start with this definition
that it is the change in velocity
compared to the change in time
so far so good now this is good this is
something that i can work with because
if i want to change the variable like
this might this is all in terms of time
at the moment right so we might have had
that a sign nt plus alpha and then we
differentiate with respect to time
off you go okay how would i change the
variable
now i want you to think back to
extension one think about the
integration that we've done recently
if you want to change a variable say you
introduce a substitution into an
integration
right essentially what you're doing is
you're using
chain rule do you agree no chain rule
works it change you like you introduce a
u
and then you've got a d u on dx and then
you've got a dx on etc
right so what i want to do here is take
this derivative it's a derivative
and i want to use chain rule i want to
chain together a pair of derivatives
that will help me change this to no
longer be in terms of time
okay yes ju are you going to give me a
suggestion for what two derivatives or
you can ask a question or
okay if you know the answer yet before
you get to that right i wanna
because some of you may already know how
to do this right i want you to see
why we're doing what we're doing right
if i'm going to come from here which is
dv on dt
then there has to be dv somewhere on the
top and that's to be a dt somewhere on
the bottom do you agree otherwise
there's no continuous connection okay
so then really the question just becomes
stock standard chain rule
what do i put here like i need the same
thing to be in both of these spots
so that it will cancel and go back to
there otherwise it's not actually equal
right now when you have a look on the
board in terms of where we are trying
to head to what do you think is an
appropriate candidate to try and
introduce to change our variable
how about dx because i'm trying to get
to acceleration as a function of
displacement
so if i go ahead and put a dx here and
here
do you agree i haven't done anything
dramatic i've just kind of done a
reverse of the chain rule usually
channel goes in that direction
okay progress i've introduced this
the x's which weren't here at all okay
i'm on my way
what's this thing here this uh dx on oh
no it's here
this dx on dt we wrote it right above
right this is just by definition
velocity change in displacement compared
to change in time
so what i can do is just stick it over
here by convention
if i write that just as v there's
velocity
and then i have this other thing over
here dv on
dx see this line right here this is
important we've made a fundamental
change
we are no longer thinking like all my
t's are gone do you see that
right so this is no longer acceleration
in terms of time
this is acceleration in terms of v here
v there
this is acceleration as a function of
velocity does that make sense
so if i have some situation like my jet
aircraft before
where i understand the force acting on
something the acceleration
being in relation to the velocity then
this is a really helpful way
to say what the acceleration is
certainly much more helpful than this
okay so this line right here let's call
this
acceleration as a function of
velocity okay
i need to go further though right i'm
trying to get in terms of not velocity i
want to get over to displacement
so you know that trick that i used
before which was to use chain rule right
i can do it again right i can use chain
rule again
to get rid of here i got rid of this dt
right see this
dt is here and then it's sort of gone
through this substitution i want to do
this again
i've got a dv on dx here
right and i want to introduce some
derivative gets rid of these
dv's right because i want to get to just
being in terms of x's
so i need to have some d on dv here do
you see that's
going to cancel things out for me this
dv and this dv will cancel
just like this dx and this dx yeah
so then the question is what do i put in
here
i want this to correspond to something
on the previous line
now have a look i've got my dv on dx
it's just unchanged
right so where this section of my line
has to come from
is here d on dv of something gives me v
d on dv of something tell me the thing
that you differentiate
with respect to v that will give you v
now the way you could do that is now if
you're thinking of displacement you're
actually thinking in terms of not
velocity but
time right if i integrate up with
respect to time i will get displacement
but here i'm trying to integrate with
respect to v with respect to velocity
right so to get from here to here is
actually
an integration step do you agree
because if i integrate this way then i
differentiate that which is actually
what i want
so can someone tell me what's the
integral of v
with respect to v
i raise the power and then divide by my
new power
right we're so much so used to thinking
of this in terms of x's that like just
because it's a v
would look at a bit funny right but do
you agree if i differentiate this with
respect to v
power comes out the front power reduces
by one you get v are you okay with that
all right now as promised i did this
whole reverse chain rule thing again
so that i could cancel out what was
happening on those duties that i didn't
want
i didn't want the dvs and i can cancel
them now
right what do i get i get d
of half a squared that's a bit weird
we're not used to seeing
something more than just a single letter
after the differential operator there
right that's what's on the top and then
tell me have a look at this line
after the dvs cancel what's left on the
bottom
dx that's literally the only thing left
once you cross these things out here
d x have a look at this line
this just like we started with up here
here's a derivative with respect to time
this is a derivative with respect to
displacement
this is acceleration
as a function of x of displacement
it's kind of bothering me a little bit
that i've used f twice because they are
clearly not the same function
so i'll use a g there you go i really
probably should have done that the first
time
but what we've done here is we have gone
back from
our definition for acceleration and
we've done some
calculus black magic to change it
instead of being
with reference to time it's now with
respect to
displacement now these are weird looking
results and using them is a bit
strange and unusual but you've got a
little bit of help with it if you go
back to
your trusty friend the reference sheet
we've looked at this before right on the
very last page in the sort of extension
2e section
let me zoom in for you because i have
terrible eyesight right here's the
mechanics section
now if you have a look we focused on
these lines down here before simple
harmonic motion
and we are fully ignored this line
underneath the heading look at it again
closely you can see the dv
on dt there which was our where we
started with as
our definition for acceleration but
notice that
if you're the first derivative of
velocity you're also the second
derivative of displacement
star from displacement go down twice to
get to acceleration and then those other
two results on the right hand side
they're the ones that we just worked out
now
acceleration as a function of velocity
is the third one
acceleration as a function of
displacement is
the last one